attaque qui a laissé des traces ce lundi
peut avant midi le son des bombardements
russes à retenti sur Kiev fait rare
cette attaque s'est déroulée en pleine
journée faisant quelques dégâts
matériels à l'image de ce véhicule
touché par les explosions tandis que des
débris 2006 jonchent cette route
au début ils essayaient d'abattre les
missiles comme d'habitude et l'un d'eux
est tombé sur la route l'arrière comme
vous le voyez à endommagé une voiture
j'ai entendu dire qu'une voiture avait
été incendiée
très vite au déclenchement des sirènes
d'alerte les habitants de Kiev ce sont
abrités dans les sous-sols de la
capitale le métro comme dernier rempart
alors que l'attaque est en cours
certains tentent de joindre leurs
proches
j'ai vu 6 7 8 un certain nombre
d'explosions dans le ciel c'est pourquoi
je suis venu ici avec mes collègues ils
sont quelque part dehors je les ai vus
et je me suis assis ici j'attends la fin
de l'alarme
lancés par la Russie mais cette nouvelle
attaque survient seulement quelques
heures après des bombardements nocturnes
russes contre des aérodromes ukrainiens
un assaut revendiqué par Moscou
l'objectif des frappes a été atteint
toutes les cibles désignées ont été
détruites
ces nouvelles frappes russes
interviennent deux jours après l'attaque
de drone la plus importante turquienne
depuis le début de la guerre signe que
Moscou a intensifié ses attaques
aériennes contre la capital ukrainienne
visée une 14e fois au mois de mai